[موسيقى]
كان مصدر الإلهام
هو فيلم "الجمال والوحش"
الذي ننظر إليه على أنه الوردة المسحورة
ويطلق عليه اسم "بيلا" ، فهذا يعني أنه
[موسيقى
] إيطالية جميلة ، يبدأ بعملية بسيطة جدًا
تتم من خلالها إضافة الجلسرين
بقطعة  حماية معينة للألوان
بمجرد الانتهاء من ذلك ، نطلق هذه العناصر
مرة أخرى في الشمس ،
وبالتالي فإن أي بكتيريا أو
أي شيء ضار سوف يتبخر مع
أشعة الشمس
فوق البنفسجية بمجرد وصولنا إلى منشأتنا في
زقاق الجبل ، يمكنهم ترتيب
المنتجات وفقًا للعميل
طلبات
[موسيقى]
هؤلاء العملاء عادة ما يكونون من الشخصيات المؤثرة في
بعض الأحيان يكون
المشاهير هم الأشخاص الوحيدون الذين
سيكونون منطقيًا بالنسبة لهم
لشراء مثل هذه الزهرة باهظة الثمن
[موسيقى]
الشيء الأكثر شيوعًا الذي يحب
الناس فعله هو إهداء
وردة البيلا باللون الأسود  وهذا
عادة لإنهاء العلاقة
[موسيقى
] أريد أن تتم مشاركة هذه السعادة وهذا المفهوم
مع الجميع في جميع أنحاء
العالم